[Music]
welcome everybody to YouTube's show me
review everybody the show where I review
means today of course we're starting off
with this smash meme oh boy oh boy this
meme really took off incredible well you
know everyone that invested in this meme
sell sell sell this meme is officially
reached its peak it's not going any
further trust me on this one
and especially as I'm about to review it
you know what's gonna die it said it's
over before you smash meme it's been a
good run though so let's go through it
some of my favorites it's gonna be
August 25th for everybody it's gonna be
late
[Music]
mr. fish you're not
August 25th everybody hey it's the
moderator yes was gonna be
who is it it's still Wellard oh no and
polkan friend Wow
what will our going to turn up take name
confirm that's pretty good it's pretty
good I like when they're themed you know
there's an anime version there is a case
I versus Logan Paul Burton could I be a
peopie version that'd be pretty cool
he must be a really strong character I
wonder what he's specialist telling
people often then walking away this is
robbery
[Music]
for reals doh this is getting old for
you I feel like it's getting it's
getting a big sale isn't it
she's got an antique ill spell on her oh
yeah there's a vine edition all bad
Instagram comedians she's latina you
guys heard about this I don't even know
where that is
yes hell no okay this meme gets a point
infinity because good means never dies
all right let's move on
no more smash means dude how do you feel
[Music]
some of these are so creative this man
gets to cannot return everybody this
fashioning is sufficiently complete we
need none more nothing stop stop stop
stop
respect the back all right guys moving
on please so leave a like for elk a LZ o
8 if you're a fan of the lkl zo8 please
smash like on this video right now just
for it we're doing a survey here in this
channel it's not sponsored it's just a
way for us to know how many people
really out there like CLK l08 cuz you
know a lot of girls be like I want that
LK easy si el single drinking fountain
although me personally I'm more of an
elk al z o8 kind of guy and I don't
discriminate against anyone sales
preferences I respect them too much to
give my opinion about women just so we
can be clear okay we would like for el
que la maybe f8 and then give a sub for
an easy si el alright wishing well I
wish to be irresistible to men booth
okay model easy and say wait a minute
there's a sticker it comes up instead
you're starting to make I know it it's
the same me hey leave it like guys if
you enjoy an extra scon 600 to 500 BC
for this name gets of course a nectar
scon 600 to 500 BC rating but ding
moving on this mean it's a little
stranger danger
Ohio man arrested for trying to have sex
with a van hmm strange then see man
arrested for stealing five pounds of
baby powder from CP okay alright alright
okay good alright man kills his
girlfriend
because they couldn't chase hoes
together anymore this is so say Alexa
can we play when will I see you again
[Music]
that's not the right song Alexa all
these criminals in America and their
headlines you think what's behind their
motive what drives them to do these
deeds well there's nothing more
incomprehensible action than the Florida
man you heard about the Florida man the
Florida man dials 911 a ride home to
change his underwear Florida strike one
the Florida man arrested for attempting
to break into jail Florida strikes to a
Florida man in jail after making a big
to-do about missing a can of shrimp
Jason laughs men allegedly attacks
Michael Earhart winds soared over
missing shrimp Florida strikes three my
shrimp my shrimp
I'm from Florida excuse me Florida are
you okay what is happening in Florida
you think it ends there Florida man
arrested for refusing to stop member
bbear in Burger King great picture there
great picture you got there this has to
be my favorite floor in a headline it
says Florida man arrested for twisting
two year-olds baby boy's nipple off
Florida strikes again but it what they
just came up I swear to God I was just
barely touching they just fell off you
know what I think I didn't even touch
him the air briefs from my finger make
the full lock there were very sensitive
nipples clearly the nipples are at fault
here all these crimes are not a joke
okay I'm not trying to make light of any
situation here this is clearly very
serious but there's one
man that I am willing to forgive
completely one man whose actions are
above the legal system one Florida man
kidnapped scientist to make his dog
immortal are you sorry mr. scientist you
come with me we need to save this doc
okay all right I'm not a veterinary but
I see what I could make him immortal
Florida man meme get Sun five five five
lip-syncing app music ally has been
killed off what music Elly has been shut
down elixir face is so awesome yay no
one asked who will I now go to watch
crazy kids online
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you have to keep being a furry a
secret why you have to call it coming
out I want to die thank God thank God I
don't know how to rate this meme I just
since this cringing he is in anguish he
mourns where this is monster have to
moan Alexa this is actually sad he is in
anguish he moods what does this monster
have to mow Alex jump may review
everybody YouTube's YouTube YouTube
YouTube thanks for watching and I'll see
you tomorrow with another book I'm here
every day
what does he get up with angst Lavoie
cool bye